but I just don't condone the bashing of
Dak Prescott and the Dallas Cowboys and
have the same energy for the
Eagles the Eagles were healthy they had
Jaylen Herz they had the receiver Court
they had their explosive weapon they
didn't have Lane Johnson I will admit
that they didn't have Lane Johnson but
does that make that big of a difference
because I see my
quarterback you know maybe not have the
red zone success but mve Devall way
better than the Eagles did
uh Sunday night so we want the same
energy for everybody because there's a
whole bunch of bashing when is Dak
Prescott but not the same one is the
Eagles I got time today okay a lot of
people said the Browns defense was
overhyped everyone said Michel don't no
ball I said the Browns are the real deal
if they could put it together they could
be a hard team to beat and now I can say
it we miss my guy who we miss very much
Omar Cooper Bal the hell out like he
could have been the dog of the week what
he did to help lead his team over the
49ers was amazing that catch was
spectacular
um the Browns and and I heard a quote AO
said this which which pissed me off he
said I'm not worried about the 49ers
they were missing Christian mcaffrey
they were missing Debo Samuel this what
piss me off about that okay they started
that game the Browns were missing
Deshawn Watson they were missing Nick
chub they were missing Jack cin they
were missing them key
factors before the game even started so
why is it that we are just scrubs and
we're nobodies that don't deserve to be
on the field and we're just all talk but
there's aund excuses for these other
these other teams like if y'all just G
to hate Cowboys Nation just say y'all
hate Cowboys Nation but don't say here
and throw shade on us keep the same
energy for everybody that's all it is
the bronze is a good team they are going
to continue to progressing and be a
great team I don't I don't know if we
have the stat line but bring it up I
think they gave up over a th a thousand
their third best and uh six game span
it's like a thousand some yards I saw
that statistic like that's amazing
defense this Browns defense is a real I
said if they could put it together they
have all the pieces they have miles
Garrett um I mean Denzel Ward I mean
they still Grant delpit Maron like I'm
going just keep going about this Browns
defense that I see that a lot of people
are stepping on if their offense could
get it together they're going to be a
playoff team which I said week one
everything I stated I told you I'm never
gonna get on this podcast and say unlike
these other analysts who don't want to
do their job and just say uh players
trash or they're bad at football which
isn't true if you're in the NFL you're a
good football play I'm never gonna get
on this and say you're bad at football
okay let's just put like these anst are
too lazy to do their job and actually
look at football and look at lineups but
I will and we're going to go through the
breakdowns and do the real talking
everything that c since week one have
have not failed and has been true and
we're just I just calling out I just
want the same energy for everybody
because people I feel like those
analysts are failing
you okay now it's oh so now we should
look at the Jets now okay the Jets have
a chance to be a really good team okay
they just beat The Undefeated eagles
which people said was impossible to do
um and the the significant part is that
I think that's great about the Jets is
they lost sace they lost their DJ Reid
um they're without Aaron Rogers but
they're saying if we could beat the best
team I don't know what more of a
confidence booster what was it three
picks and they had a force fumble in
that game if they're saying if we could
beat the best team in the NFL which
people say right um and we're doing this
without our star players how special can
we really be and that's the significant
part about adversity and the next man up
mentality and that's the part that a lot
of people don't want to talk about in
football in life think about in life all
right if you get punched in the face
right okay you get punched in the
face how do you react after you get
punched in the face like like if you
lose your job do you say oh my gosh I
lost my job like I can't move on or do
you say oh I got to go start applying I
gotta get back on my feet I gotta find a
new job I gotta like that's important
into how great they want to be the
leadership that's in the Jets locker
room is amazing and I'm loving to see it
like I said I I hope the best for the
Jets because everyone trashed on them
everyone trashed on Zach and I'm loving
the turnaround I'm loving it because
before before when we beat him it was
like they're nobodies who cares you know
um especially after they beat the bills
on uh what was that Sunday night or
Monday night the first week so I'm
loving to see it I'm sorry you guys do
not pay attention to these trash
analysts who just come out there and
rant after one game and I'm not even
saying the 49ers shouldn't have won the
game they had a chance to win the game
but I'm saying the Browns defense is a
real deal this is a special team that
they are building they still didn't have
deshan Waton they're still missing their
two All Pro players so it's it's special
to see and I'm just calling out the BS
because I'm tired of people trashing my
quarterback I'm tired of people trashing
my team and that's why I had nothing to
say to the me this week I just wanted us
to say you want to hear me talk come
hear me talk on the edge Monday night um
and and that's just what it's GNA be
because I have nothing to say because if
you're just gonna take one game and say
this is who I am then I have nothing to
say to you because then life that's just
not how it is um it and that's Point
Blank period not one moment in your life
where ever Define you you have the next
day you have a beautiful opportunity
that day will end and if you're blessed
enough you have if you're blessed enough
to wake up the next day then you have
you you have a chance to redeem yourself
you have a chance to get better you have
a chance to learn so just take that
lesson from the just take that lesson
chat and that's all I'm G say about that
I'm glad we can move on from that um
because you know I'm I'm just tired of
the disrespect and and that's just point
blank period um and I'm tired and I want
y'all to get the full breakdown of what
sports really is